trente ans après la catastrophe de
tchernobyl et cinq années après celle de
fukushima le collectif sortir du
nucléaire organisé sa traditionnelle
marche à travers montigny le bretonneux
en se souvenant on se rappelle aussi que
le nucléaire pour nous c'est une énergie
lié à la mort c'est pas du tout une
énergie qui renouvelables en plus après
ces derniers jours le plan pluriannuel
de l'énergie est pas du tout conforme à
la loi de transition énergétique qui a
été votée il ya quelques mois plusieurs
organisations réunis autour d'une même
lutte pour interpeller la population
attaque la levée greenpeace et partis de
gauche mais aussi les étudiants c'est
aussi une marche de la jeunesse actuelle
quand on voit l'âge des centrales
nucléaires quand on voit justement les
accidents qui se sont déroulés on a peur
pour notre avenir il faut que toutes les
occasions soit bonne pour être dans la
rue pour s'exprimer pour dire que c'est
l'avenir que l'on veut il est différent
de celui que la société nous impose
il ya de plus en plus d'études qui
montrent que la production d'énergie que
ce soit solaire ou éolien est beaucoup
plus rentable que de continuer dans la
l'énergie nucléaire une vingtaine de
personnes se sont rendus jusqu'au site
areva pour déposer une gerbe de fleurs
un acte symbolique pour un mouvement qui
rassemble difficilement car selon le
collectif
le nucléaire sûr vais pour les français
un sujet trop éloignés de leurs
problématiques quotidiennes